the trailer for a mission that has all
the makings of a Hollywood thriller the
oceans of our life our life
and 95% of them remain on
the nekton mission will go to places
never explored diving into the darkness
of the twilight zone where life may
exist informs never seen before to
discover the secrets of the deep
before the oceans demise triggers
the scientists have already surveyed the
seas around Bermuda next month they'll
use submersibles to check the health of
deepwater coral reefs in the Seychelles
many species spend part their life
saying the mangrove forests will part
their lives in the seagrass bed before
migrating as they grow to coral reef so
if we lose the coral reefs then other
ecosystems in the region are affected by
them they're up against it the u.s.
ocean monitoring agency has tracked a
surge of warm water and the likely
damage it does to coral as it spreads
across the Indian Ocean so this is like
a mini reef at the University of Derby
scientists are studying the impact on
coral of rising sea temperatures caused
by climate change it turns a ghostly
white this is the bleaching process in
closer and got some coral here that's
been stressed for a few days
now under the heat of the microscope
lights it's really not reacting very
well at all you can see on the screen
here the brown algae that gives the
coral its color and its main food source
are being expelled if this continued for
a few more days the coral would die a
quarter of marine life depends on coral
reefs for food shelter or a place to
raise their young already half of all
shallow reefs have been reduced to
rubble almost all the rest will follow
if the Seas continue to warm usually too
far offshore reefs
Sky News we'll be with the scientists as
they look for evidence that deeper coral
reefs are more likely to survive climate
change already the Seychelles government
is taking action to protect great
Suede's of its ocean territory we have a
modern sea shows which goes like this
our children our treasures so if we do
not look after the resources and they
will have to enjoy when we are gone and
who are we
new research by the Met Office suggests
global temperatures will hit a record
high in the next five years the coral
reefs will feel the brunt and the
research of the nekton scientists could
be critical Thomas More Sky News